in the lobby a financial piece Plaza
clay is with us hey clay welcome to
Nashville thank you good to be here good
to have you where do you live
just outside of Dallas in Forney Texas
Oh fun and what are you doing in
Nashville a debt free scream anything
else that's it fine fun so how much have
you paid off about 44,000 and how long
did it take you to do that 16 months 16
months making what kind of money started
out around 65 and uh a little over 100
by the time I was done good for you what
do you do for a living working the wool
fields good for you
very cool hard work but get paid well
yes sir yeah I love it very good and so
16 months you're obviously I'm guessing
you're a single guy I am okay so 16
months ago you decide to get out of debt
tell me your story well like I said I
work in the wool fields and I had a work
injury that made it to where I could
work on the rigs anymore and I was in a
truck running parts all day and it was
just uh just a load time for me
personally and I had no idea how
horrible my finances were but my heart
was just in a bad space and I needed
some positivity so I'm flipping through
the radio stations and here's this guy
with a southern accent talking about
he's better than he deserves and I just
wanted to hear more about it and at
first I just listened to the show for
entertainment purposes I like the way
you help people and after a while it's
just like all this truth just gets
ingrained in my mind then I realized
that my life financially is just that a
mess and you know I have two kids a
seven-year-old a two-year-old and and I
and I I just I made the decision that
the mess that I had is that's the end of
it and I wanted to do something
different for myself and I wanted to do
something different for my boys so that
was it time to kick in their overtime
and get this thing taken care of so
that's what I did that's what got you
started huh very cool that's neat and so
kicked just listening on the radio that
was the whole deal yes sir well how I
love it
that's very fun what kind of debt was
the forty four thousand some of it was
family loans bought a house a while back
for my two kids and their mother and
they we had a family loan to take care
of the so we wouldn't have PMI and then
I had some
debt consolidation I had other small
loans I had some restitution restitution
that I had to take care of what
restitution tell me about that well I
used to be a bank robber and I served
some time in prison and whoa yes sir and
I got out August 31st of 2010 and when
you take money from people that you know
it's their money and you take it you
have to pay it back so fancy word for
that is restitution
gotcha so how much was that um I
probably shouldn't uh split up and just
say okay you're right uh uh but the
legal deal yeah I can say it's less than
44-thousand we know that it is and did
you have other loans what kind of other
debt did you have um I had a I brought
notes just in cats okay brain gave out
on me um I had a 401k loan uh before I
knew how bad that was sure had some
medical bills from when my son was born
that was not too much and then like I
said the debt consolidation and then
also some taxes that I owed quite a bit
from all the overtime and I about my
income up to an extent that I owed more
taxes um and that hurt got the hole on
there okay and the last thing I paid off
was the restitution that was actually
just Friday I went Wow yeah the last
little chunk of that was down in the
courthouse in downtown Dallas at the
federal building down there took them
their money order and it was that was it
I feels kind of like a portion of the
past that really needs to be left in the
past is over Oh buddy you have no idea
how bad I mean when when I left the 14th
floor there and and I don't want to
exaggerate but to say that it's the same
as the day that I got out of prison is
how I felt when I got in the button and
I pushed one on the elevator to get out
of that place and I was done that was it
and my past was in the past let it don't
anybody anymore the end of it I loved it
praise God that's awesome man how long
were you incarcerated about three and a
half years little over three years Wow
three years three months and ten days
okay yeah and give or take a minute yeah
oh my goodness
but that's all behind you now is so cool
good for you
proud of you man very cool hard work
overtime a goal and a whole different
kind of freedom when you do when you
yelled that free today huh mm-hmm that's
different than just paying off a little
MasterCard because you get the federal
government foot for restitution off your
back that's that's a big monkey off the
back it's a it's a that's the nice way
to put it but you know I put myself in
that position so you know when you have
to man up and take care of what you did
you just do it and it's not anybody's
fault but mine the situation that I was
in and to bring myself to be done with
it is is a big deal and actually this
Sunday is the four-year anniversary of
the day I got out of prison so this
whole week has August 31st is a big big
day to me I celebrate it pretty hard not
bad yeah so that I be doing the Snoopy
dance if I was in your shoes man you're
doing more than that you're even in
Hawley you know all about grace huh I do
yeah that's very cool well I'm proud of
you you're only my favorite people to
talk to this whole week absolutely
incredible what an incredible story and
and some extra layers obviously don't
what you're facing so let me ask you
this you're how old are you 35 35 you
make $100,000 a year working your butt
off you don't have any payments what's
the future look like an emergency fund
is first on the list I'm actually got
into it a few hundred bucks to to pay
that little bit of restitution off so I
gotta get that up and get that
established and I have a seven-year-old
he'll be eight in a couple months who's
learning the principles of working and
earning money and stuff like that um so
I really want to focus on well first of
all I want to cut down on all the
overtime I'm working because I didn't
get a raise I just literally over timed
myself and to making the extra money so
I would like to scale it back and spend
more time with my family and just slow
it down a bit and and now that I'm done
with this giant hurdle we can go forward
from this point the way that that I
should and I don't even know how it
should I mean I've never taken a class
but I know
that's that's my next step you're
definitely taking it on us we're going
to definitely donate that to you when
you leave here thank you there's no
question you're you're you're an
inspiration and you know I got to tell
you that one of my favorite parts of the
whole conversation is how you describe
your shoulders and man up and go it was
me
and I'm one made the mess I'm the man
I'm cleaning this up and I think there's
about eight million people listening
this show right now that are going amen
and a few of them that need to hear that
that they need a man up on something we
all do occasionally we all got to take
ownership I remember when I went broke I
blamed everybody else for a little while
and then one day I finally figured out
it was my fault and that was probably
the turning point for my whole life was
taking responsibility for my actions and
you definitely did that beautifully that
is uh that's where it changed I mean
it's when you when you start realizing
who the problem is and you can work on
the actual problem and that's that's
that's the same with me that's where it
started with myself and it went out from
there absolutely
clay you're neat man so honored to meet
you I wanted to hang out with you today
very very cool love it all right clay
from Dallas Texas forty-four thousand
dollars paid off in 16 months making 65
with overtime up to a hundred and he is
free count it down let's hear a great
debt free scream three two one I'm dead
oh my gosh absolutely awesome absolutely
awesome
Wow gives you uh a little different take
on things huh you know really I mean
it's just it's a great metaphor for how
you got to feel if you want to get out
of that what if you felt that way about
paying off your car or felt that way
about paying off your student loan that
when you pushed one on that Bank
building elevator and you're leaving
after having paid it off that you felt
like he did see that that's when people
move the needle in their lives when they
take responsibility when they man up and
then when they get passionate enough to
cause something to happen Wow
best debt free call in a while Kelly Wow
absolutely amazing he told me at the
commercial break he said I don't know if
you've ever had a bank robber on before
I thought he was kidding and then I came
in here and start talking to him and he
visit restitution I went oh he wasn't
wasn't kidding Wow
this is the Dave Ramsey show
is awesome man you have the whole world
crying good a lot of story
well I can't breathe I was trying to
keep from crying like a girl oh my gosh
me too I just I couldn't pull it off
I was afraid about you were gonna get
their free scream I had to we got to get
there get there he's gonna lose it
yeah oh man that's powerful thank you
good for you good for you can't thank
you enough for just the positivity that
you bring because that's what got me I
mean if I flipped and just heard dollars
and that I would just kept going when I
hear that better than I deserve that
kind of that caught my curiosity was
amazing and and a month into this one it
was like I'm learning stuff what the
heck is it's God's Spirit that's cool
very very cool I'm proud of you like
honor to meet you services thank you for
telling your story beautifully done
thank you if you've been watching the
video channel you saw clay Toomey's
amazing story as he did his debt-free
screen if you didn't see it three hours
from now check it out as it rolls the
next 24 hours unbelievable story when
those powerful debt-free screams ever
seen here's where we're at clay spent
time in jail almost three years in
prison for robbery he gets out pays off
44 thousand dollars in 16 months and
just last week you paid off your final
restitution payment I want you to talk
about second chances because you've been
given a chance now and you've made the
most of it what would you say to people
who feel like they can't fix the mess
they've created well first of all you
can I mean there's nothing saying that
you can't accept yourself so for me it
was about realizing that there is some
work to be done and that's the first
step for me after that you just have to
figure out how to do it and how to go
about it devise a plan like dave says
and just execute it and you know and
believe in yourself and don't let this
stigma of being a felon or being a
screw-up or being a whatever
don't let that define who you are and
then just get after it there it is get
after this man is truly free free from
prison free from debt and really free
from his past he's moving for it was an
incredible moment clay thank you for
being here and sharing that with us
folks clay is what this show and hope is
about
you